you like to host parties and and get  your guests to improvise opera yeah I  don't understand how someone can  improvise opera well you need a good  pianist and you need crazy people to be  there and to think that they are opera  singers you should have me over sometime  I am an amazing I have an operatic range  can we try what do you want what do you  want to do use conduct me in our honor  or 10 Orry soprano soap I don't know Oh  No why would you say that I don't know  somebody told me that no they did not  know I know I could but I have a very an  amazing body tone but uh tenor I'm in  the tenor range give me a ten all right  we'll give me some units Reed I do  [Applause]  to me goes right so you're agreeing to  let me be in the you come be my next  role old for love way hey thanks for  watching be sure to click subscribe to  see even more great Conan clips you may  now return to your pirated movies and  creepy Japanese pornography